okay so the second and final theatrical
trailer to James Cameron's Avatar be
online next week but and I'm here to
review it for you good people first of
all let's take a moment to clear from
this understanding that apparently still
exists in the world avatar is not the
last airbender this is not this the last
airbenders being made by a director who
used to make good movies avatar is being
made by a director who used to make
movies
oh come on a 10 year hiatus deserves a
jab but after 10 years the King has
returned and has given us a new trailer
to his epic avatar
ok so let's be honest the teaser trailer
was pretty much a technological showcase
for the much talked-about much hyped up
CGI in Avatar it left you knowing
nothing about the plot and it left you
wondering which I was fine with because
that's what it's supposed to do tease I
mean think of it t--'s no one ever goes
up to a girl they think is a tease and
says you're such a tease and it's
everything I wanted you're teasing is so
fulfilling and awesome I'm just so
pleased by your teasing in fact I don't
require anything else after that yes
even I'll admit sometimes life is just
that simple sometimes it's all in a name
it's a teaser trailer meant to tease but
this new trailer is the final trailer
this is supposed to blow away the teaser
in a three-and-a-half minute onslaught
of emotion and personal conflict on an
epic scale that makes booty Yahweh and
the Christ child himself set holy
dude I got to see that and for my money
they said something like that
this trailer obliterates the teaser
trailer we now have the very epic
trailer that we've been waiting to sink
our teeth to do for eons now James
Cameron has soared past the ball
tickling teaser trailer and showing us
once again why he is though man
safe to say the final trailer gets past
the CGI showcase if the teaser trailer
and gives us a trailer worth talking
about so in the trailer Sam Worthington
scare actor Jake Sully is approached by
someone about going to the planet
Pandora and making a real difference
what he apparently doesn't know is that
the indigenous population of Pandora is
about to get fist by the military
as most of us already knew there's
something on the planet that we want and
the natives are pissed and what we
finally find out in this trailer is that
there's something that we want is a rock
or a mineral on that planet
it's coveted by us for reasons unknown
all we find out from the trailers at
this rock sells for a gargantuan amount
of money on eBay thoughts I can at least
say that the trailer doesn't know lewd
for there being any other reason for us
being on Pandora except this rock it
does seem a little like that doesn't it
I mean that's it
we just want a rock I mean does the rock
do something extraordinary like tear
cancer or make Twilight watchable who
knows maybe there's hidden agendas but
of course they luck would have it
the knobby settlement happens to be a
ride on top of the largest deposit of
this rock and so what do we do we
relocate them because that's just not
gonna piss them off at all yeah that
never works out well and now we're at
war after that it looks like it has kind
of this Dances with Wolves or Last
Samurai and space tone to it which works
fine with me cuz I love both those
movies I just love a movie where someone
realizes they're fighting for the
so they take action to help the
underdog fight off the douchebags and if
you're still insisting on saying that
this movie looks like ferngully in space
or some this trailers not gonna do
anything to subside that talk
simply on the basis that it shows
machinery tearing down trees yeah we
really want those rocks as I've seen
Jurassic Park looks like the Land of the
Lost TV show if someone watches this
trailer and still says it looks like
Fern Gully they're just talking
don't even listen to him the trailer is
so badass
you see I move from a simple Navi
relocation program to full-scale war you
see them Nobby writing in a battle on
their horses with bows and arrows
against mechs with rockets
yeah those Navi had balls so it appears
that all worried about this movie being
a three-hour borefest can be laid to
rest this movie looks like it's gonna be
a three-hour full-scale emotional epic
of war conflict strife and sacrifice
that ultimately encompasses all the
reasons that people make movies once in
a long while a movie comes along that
straight up shows us why movies are made
and after seeing this new trailer avatar
has a really good shot at being one of
those movies
the CGI in this new trailer does look
more impressive than the last trailer
but I challenge you look past the CGI
avatar now looks like more than just a
CGI showcase it looks like a great movie
and I will have my avatar review up the
moment I see the film so when the
trailer comes out watch it let me know
what you think